foreign
let's go out to Dallas Texas and talk to
tmoney let's talk to Trent what's up
Trent
hey how are you partying man what about
you
man I'm doing I'm doing all right thank
you so much for having me on the show
I'm a huge fan it's an honor to get to
talk to you right now I appreciate that
man what's up
hey uh so I've been struggling for a
while like prob probably like the last
three years like a lot of people
um and I'm just wondering how do you
how do you like reconcile mistakes that
you've made in your past and like
still find a way to uh
excuse me
um to feel fulfilled in life um I'm kind
of in a place right now where I just
don't know
if I'm ever going to be able to feel
just peace what'd you do that's so bad
that this many years later you can't
breathe
see the issue is uh
I have a lot of Shame about feeling this
way so
if you don't mind I'll take you back to
about 20 20 it was it was 2020. um and
I'm sitting on the couch in my apartment
with my wife
and I'm not happy I'm depressed because
of covid and the quarantine and it's all
got us all shut down and I'm sitting
there thinking about I don't know if
this is the life that I want I have no
idea what I'm going to do I don't know
if I want to stay married those kind of
things
um how long have you been married
uh four years now so you're about about
a year in
yeah okay so people tell me no no no no
no you were about a year in when you
started having this like what am I doing
yes yeah so before we keep going I just
want to socially Norm that's the nerd
word I want to
let you know I had those exact same
thoughts
in fact I sat down with my wife and said
I don't think we've done the right thing
what do we do next how do we untangle
this because this is not gonna work and
that was 21 years ago okay so I want you
to know you're not crazy that's a super
common sitting there next to somebody
going what have I done
okay right okay so bring it keep going
yeah and as I'm laying on the couch
having those thoughts and I'm not really
showing it but like inside I'm just full
of turmoil you're showing it and uh it's
all over the place but go ahead no no no
no I'm sure
I'm shook out of the bathroom and she
goes hey babe I'm pregnant
um hello
yeah
not planned uh definitely wasn't our
idea to get pregnant in the middle of
that whole mess that was going on and um
you know I feel so bad because she had
always wanted a kid and uh
you know you see those videos of Lies
when they tell their husbands that
they're pregnant and the husband just
has this overflowing reaction of joy and
it's this heartfelt thing and I lay
there on the couch and had a panic
attack
okay
I'm just telling you all this to give
you some background of What's led me to
where I'm at today
um well and I'm hearing it and if you
were here if you were watching me live
you would see like
that doesn't surprise me and there it
would have been neat to have an
Instagram moment and it would have been
cool to like be flooded with emotions
but we were in the middle of an
international
Health crisis that might kill us all and
so your first instinct your body went oh
no I can barely Keep Us Alive much less
a child that's not crazy in fact I would
think it was more normal than going all
right right you know what I mean right
right
no for sure and then uh and I I've I've
battled with depression and anxiety my
since I was a teenager like it's
something I've dealt with it kind of
ends and flows up and down uh you just I
just manage it and uh
so
over the last few years you know when
she said I was pregnant I put all my
feelings aside and was like well okay
regardless of how I feel for the
marriage like
I want to give my daughter a you know a
complete family a household I want to be
a good dad and I want to be present
so that's what I've been trying to do
so we moved out of our apartment got
into a house and like now fast forward a
long time I'm in a lot of debt uh
I work a hard job I just this is just I
feel like if 18 year old me was looking
at 27 year old me he'd be so
disappointed
and your 18 year old you was an idiot
I know I'm sure he is right yeah he was
he was 18 year old me based on a weekly
schedule followed Pantera around and was
like you know what I mean like the 18
year old me was insane I hope 18 year
old me doesn't like me that tells me
I've grown up some
sure like that's a that's a bad
comparison
that's fair um and I'll admit I was a
dumb 18 year old like everybody else
um yes
my my dilemma right now is that I feel
like I have this life that so many
people really would want
and I'm so selfish that I can't find a
way to just
be content and happy in it
that's that's just what I'm dealing with
okay
um
you've talked about wanting to take care
of your wife you talked about wanting to
take care of your kid
what happened to Trent that Trent thinks
Trent sucks
why do you think so little of Trent that
Trent is worth having a peaceful life
which by the way is the greatest gift
you can give your kid is not a five
bedroom house but it may be a two
bedroom apartment where there's peace
because that's what y'all can afford
right now
or right maybe some significant serious
marriage counseling and your wife's got
a role to play in this too
um
where y'all create a house that's full
of warmth and laughter as much as
possible in this crazy world as opposed
to I'm gonna make sure there's this
suburban and this thing and this style
of backpack and this kind of lunch box
and so I am going to live as though I'm
on on fire so that we have this crap is
that you see what I'm saying like what
what happened to Trent because Trent
deserves so much more than the life he's
allowing himself to live
I guess I guess I'm still trying to find
that I feel like I've lost myself and I
don't think you ever had it man
you could be right there as well
because here's what it sounds like
you're trying to do it sounds like
you're trying to get to a particular
Finish Line and that Finish Line might
be number of cars size of house
um uh number of kids a number of times
you have sex in a week
um net worth whatever metric you're
putting up for yourself as normal uh
whatever that's supposed to mean and
you're trying to achieve peace and the
you've heard me say this a million times
on the show the crappiest part about
making a hundred thousand dollars for
the first time is that you go with you
you're the one that cashes that paycheck
and if you don't like yourself with 40
Grand you are not gonna like yourself
with 100 Grand and you're gonna hate
yourself with a million
yeah no that makes sense and here's my
phone can I can I be ugly for a second
like pretty direct please do no please
do
um your daughter will spend her life
wondering what it is about her
that is making you so Electric
so unhappy
and my guess is you were put in a
position to make Mom and Dad happy
is that fair
yeah don't make mom mad if you say this
dad's gonna get angry is that you
growing up
yep okay
and so what you did was your identity
becomes rooted in what other people
expect of me my job on Earth is to make
sure other people fill in the blank
and that keeps you alive when you're a
kid and when you get older you become
untethered
and you start chasing I need something
to feel good
that makes sense so the question I'll
ask you man like from the inside out
um and don't be scared of the answer
you're not gonna Shock Me
what do you want man put it put aside
the house put aside the the cars put
aside the what do you want
[Music]
that's honestly John that's the question
that I've been I've been trying to ask
myself and this is why I feel
so stuck because I feel like even if I
and I'm not I don't want to do this I'm
not going to do this but like even if I
were to
leave my family
go off and do my own thing
I'd be so miserable I would be so
miserable you'd go know that that's
right so right let me ask you um I think
an easier question but a a different one
not what do you want that's people will
go to counseling for years to answer
that question that's a hard question to
answer
what do you want your house to feel like
when you get home every day
I just want it to be
I just want it to feel
like like a home I just want to get home
what is it what does that mean because
here's I'll tell you at my house I'll
give you some words
when I walk in the door you know what I
just want to feel I want to feel like my
wife likes me
I just want to feel like she's happy I'm
there
and I I my kids are kids right so I'm
not going to Outsource my feelings to
them but I want there to be a sense of
my daughter running at me with a sword
and a pillow trying to stab me with her
imaginary thing and my son sitting there
working on his novel like a good little
nerd like I like I want it to feel like
that you see what I'm saying there's
nothing great yeah but when I did that
math
I had to get rid of a bunch of stuff
that I had taken I had taken loans out
on
because my wife didn't like me when I
was stressed out all the time and I was
stressed out when I owed a bunch of
people money all the time I
see what I'm saying so yeah when you
walk in your house what do you want it
to feel like
I guess I want that I want I want to
feel light I want that weight of of life
to just I want the world to be outside
and when I walk in I want that to not be
in the world anymore I want the weight
of everything to just be lifted off um
you talk about your kids and I don't
want to make it sound like I don't like
my family when my daughter I don't hear
that at all
okay I hear that I hear that you don't
like Trent
I hear that you love your daughter
beyond the end of time and I actually
think you love your wife beyond the end
of time you don't like that you they
have anchored themselves to you a guy
that you don't like
and you thought all of this was supposed
to feel differently
so so here here's the here's the path
you got forward okay path number one is
you keep running
and you keep achieving and you keep
hustling you keep grinding out at work
and you're gonna have a customer come in
one day and she's beautiful and
hilarious
and
she's gonna make you laugh and you're
gonna think about her and she's like
that happens to all of us right there's
beautiful hilarious people everywhere
and then she's going to come back the
next month
and then she's gonna say all right I'll
be back in two weeks for my next order
and you're gonna be waiting for her the
next time
and then you're gonna get her number and
then it all goes sideways that way okay
that's that's number one okay that
hasn't already happened some version of
that it's coming
my guess is you it's probably shown up
before the second one
is you get a babysitter for your kid and
you take your wife out and you say
the life I'm creating for us is making
me insane
and I love you more than life itself and
I've tried to show you I love you with
all this stuff
and I need to do something different
okay
I also think you need to call I'm gonna
stay on the line I'm gonna send you
um three months of free counseling with
my buddies of better help I think you
need to call and you need to ask them
like when you talk to the counselor what
are you working on today I don't like me
and my daughter deserves a husband I
mean a dad who loves himself enough to
take care of himself enough to be an
anchor my wife deserves a husband who's
not trying to use her to make himself
feel better
and I want y'all to work work through
that is that fair
totally fair
um totally fair in this uh building a
non-exist life book I just put out
um there's a chapter in there called
choose freedom and it's not like uh
Eagles and like uh American flag
underwear that's not what I mean
um yeah
it's taking a true inventory of who is
telling you what you need to be doing
every second of every day where are
those shoulds coming from or have Deuce
coming from
some of them come from a bank saying you
have to go to work tomorrow at this
crappy job because you owe me or a car
dealership or a clothing credit card or
whatever
sometimes it's in-laws telling you when
you're gonna do Christmas and how you're
gonna do whatever and my granddaughter
is not going to go to that school so you
I
and you go on and on and on down the
list and so I think an important
exercise for you I'm going to send you a
free copy of the book too but I want you
to go through that exercise
where is this voice coming from who's
the person telling me all these things
that I should be doing this and I should
feel like this and I
because what you're going to find is
it's not you
it's your mom it's your dad it's your
coach it's some well-meaning but kind of
moronic Pastor from your childhood it's
it's whoever man it's people you work
with
and at some point you have to take
ownership back of those voices does that
make sense
totally makes sense and I'll probably do
that exercise today okay that'd be I I
would love that and um dude I'd love to
have you back on with your wife sometime
you think she'd be willing to do that
um yeah I I think she would be I I
didn't tell her I was calling you today
um I was kind of embarrassed but I will
tell her that I called and uh talk to
her about this for sure I think she
would love to come on all right so just
to peek behind the curtain okay
this morning um I have a close friend
who's in a really um tough situation
with one of his kids his kids is um sick
and
um
one of the most extraordinary beautiful
little kids I've ever had the presence I
mean the the honor to meet
and he called me and asked me a question
and I thought I knew the answer but just
to make sure
um I called one of my friends um and
I've had her on the show Lynn Jennings
um Dr Jennings back there in Texas who's
an expert with working with kids and she
said in her own wonderful way with all
due respect John you're way off on this
one
and here's this and here's this and
here's why and she gave me the
developmental research because that's
how nerds talk to each other but here's
the thing I was wrong
and here's what I got the opportunity to
be a little less wrong
right like there's no shame or
embarrassment I didn't know okay so
similarly
I want you to free yourself man from the
shame and embarrassment of all right I'm
four years in I have a kid that was a
surprise and I've got a wife that we're
still figuring out do we like how we
even like each other
okay those are skills I don't have
you've never been a married for four
years with a kid this is all new cut
yourself some slack man no shame here
what you're doing is you're finding out
answers and that's gonna help you be a
better husband better dad and quite
honestly it's going to help you make
peace with Trent because I think Trent
is a pretty good guy
I think if you asked the people in your
life or if I did what do you think about
Trent they'd probably tell me good stuff
I think there's one person who doesn't
like Trent and that's you
man you can make all the money in the
world and you can get your kid all the
nice things make sure your wife is
clothed in rubies and whatever
but if you don't like you man it's all
for not
it's all for not